a lot of people think the transgender  issue the ones who poo-pooh it like Ben  is saying they say oh this cropped up in  the last five years nothing but it's  it's the same premise that you had in  feminism which is men and women are  basically the same it it flows naturally  into the gay marriage movement which is  men and women are exactly the same flows  naturally into the transgender Moon  which is men and women are exactly the  same so when you're fighting against  that you're not fighting against some  weird fad on a college campus five  minutes ago you're fighting against an  issue that has been building for at  least 60 years